is there something uh is there a
particular i have a bunch that i really
enjoy but is there something that stands
out to you as
as uh as memorable we talked about
sort of uh a defining loss perhaps the
dentist
[Music]
then um
you you faced michael tyler who
mentioned john
you've you've faced matt
um is there something that stands out to
you that uh technically or
psychologically you've
learned a lot from
i've i feel like i try and learn
something from every match but there is
a very special match to me
that to this day i can't explain uh
very weird phenomena
so
i think it was 2005
uh was my first
combat tour overseas
so
it was a
active tour
uh
you know among among other things i i
got shot during that tour like we got
blown a long tour rough tour
and i trained the whole time through
knowing that at the end of this i was
going to have a big match
so
there's a champion guy called ron bath
he's kind of if there was no john
berzink there would be ron bath
okay so
extremely decorated
unbelievable arm wrestler from the
united states
and this is kind of when i was just kind
of coming up in the sports still i was
fairly well established i was definitely
the best guy in canada and i had been
for a few years but i hadn't really
expanded internationally too much
so
i had a one-on-one match with ron bath
and
that's the one
yeah
extremely hard-fought battle
was 3-1 i think 3-1 but every match was
really close and he won the first one
and i had to kind of like dig my way out
of the trenches and uh ended up coming
back and winning but
it was a match
that was probably it was probably one of
my closest matches ever
and
[Music]
it seems like there's frustration on you
what is that what was going through your
mind here
with these uh was it first of all going
in did you think you could beat them
what was the level of con i always think
i can win like i always do
um but you know a lot of respect to the
guy um
but yeah i mean i always think i can do
it
uh so how do what lessons did you take
away from it uh why why is it so
meaningful to you
well it's what happened afterwards
so
i had some kind of a release afterwards
and that was the strange thing to me
so
match
ended
and i felt like
so relaxed afterwards so calm so uh so
you know satisfied
because it was one of those matches uh
that kind of takes everything from you
yeah but you win it
and
i was relaxing in the chair
and uh i've never had this sensation
before i've never had it afterwards
but it's like the center of my backbone
just exploded
and it was like
so weird right because i'm not really
spiritual that much or religious even
but it's like a fire just ripped through
me
and it only lasted an instant
just exploded through my whole body
out
at the top through my feet and then it
was gone that was it
uh weirdest thing i've ever felt my
entire life um
yeah but it was it was as a result of uh
what happened in the match
and leading up to it i had some kind of
a release
um so what it does it almost
how did you interpret it psychologically
was it like uh
some kind of i mean not to be spiritual
or whatever but some kind of superpower
that was uh
like
like a lingering feeling like holy
i
them you know i can't i can't explain it
and i haven't really tried hard enough
to
try to uh but something changed
something happened there yeah
something happened to me i was sore for
about three or four months afterwards
it's like it smoked out my entire body
yeah that whole summer i was kind of
sore
and uh yeah and then after that like two
or three years later that's when i i won
the world championships
um
yeah i mean all the matches are you know
you get something from people like you
know you study them
you you take something from them
people have an invisible crown
and
he had one and i think i took it from
him
you